jaurès elle alors la question qui se
pose à tout le monde maintenant y
compris à vous c'est comment imaginer
que le débat politique puisse redémarrer
écoutez je pense qu'il faut se mettre
dans la perspective dans laquelle le
peuple nous a remis le peuple a exprimé
sans un mot le plus puissant des
messages qui ait jamais été prononcé en
france depuis une cinquantaine d'années
je pense que d'abord nous devons
regarder se peut sa pomme pas des
siècles ce qui n'a pas été et peut être
même faire des excuses au peuple de
france les excuses de dollars qui
confondu parce que nous n'avons pas bien
géré ces trente dernières années
nous ne les avons pas tenu informé nous
ne leur avons pas expliqué ce que nous
faisions et au fort aujourd'hui ils se
trouvent et nous nous trouvons tous dans
l'impasse si c'est critique que vous
faites une autocritique que vous faites
mais c'est ce qui demande la somme
premier tard ils disent beaucoup d'entre
eux m'ont dit écoutez commencer par nos
écouter s'il vous plaît votez non des cô
tes nord justement justement va revenir
sur votre démarche votre marche même que
vous aviez entamé en 2013 un tour de
france à pied qui a duré huit mois on va
revoir des images qui vont vous rappeler
des souvenirs et ce qui ressort de votre
livre c'est ce sentiment de beaucoup
d'entre eux qui se sentent abandonnés
seuls loin des centres de décision est
ce que vous dites c'est que ça crée
beaucoup de craintes et de frustration
en même temps oui c'est énorme d'avoir
la farce aujourd'hui c'est un peuple qui
a peur il n'a plus confiant qu'il n'a
confiance à rien ni à personne
voilà en gros et à partir de là effectué
à mener la frustration ce sentiment
d'être loin de tout même da à
l'intérieur de la capitale ici à paris
alors je ne vous dis pas au fond des
campagnes que vous êtes allé visiter
je suis allé visiter ou des banlieues
certaines banlieues ils ont le sentiment
qu ils ne font plus partie de la vraie
et pourtant ce que vous décrivez c'est
qu'il ya toujours une histoire de ce
pays mais aussi des solidarités locales
ça existe ça et c'est ça qui permet que
ça tienne encore oui les maires en
dehors homme extraordinaire
les maires règne tous les jours des
petits conflits qui aiment venir et la
vie de la commune et des environs
je ne comprends pas qu'on s'apprête à
faire disparaître les maires de france
même si tout le monde dit non encore
mensonge encore l'élément sur lequel il
faut s'excuser tous ensemble
l'abonnement et vous vous battez le
dessus d'ailleurs vous lire dans votre
livre lors de votre tour de france qui
est notable aussi c'est que vous avez
rencontré des politiques également ou
des personnalités on va dire qu'ils font
le même constat que vous ces blocs et ça
marche pas la france est coincé il faut
changer quelque chose mais pourquoi ils
ne tirent pas les conclusions qui
s'imposent tout le monde est pétrifié
c'est très difficile savez moi il a
fallu que je vis une période
épouvantable pour entreprendre cette
marche je n'avais ni envie de marcher ni
aucun besoin d'un marché
il m'a fallu six mois de cauchemar pour
me mettre parce que je vais trouver
lâche je suis voyez je pressentais de
milliers républicaine et des autres sont
brèves seulement nous sommes assis entre
deux chaises depuis trente ans entre la
france et la construction européenne et
au fort il n'ya devrait pouvoir ni chez
lui ni chez l'autre et nous avons avancé
à la règle ainsi de cette manière alors
il faut faire quoi là maintenant alors
je crois qu'il faut d'abord prolonger le
travail de réflexion parce que si on
prend des orientations j'entends bien
les collègues qui disent il faut il faut
mais si ça va pas dans le sens où est le
peuple
mais ce sera encore pire c'est la raison
pour laquelle samedi prochain moi je
réunis tous les compagnons de route à
l'assemblée nationale salle lamartine à
10 heures voilà les niveaux pour refaire
un point d'étape philo faire un point
d'étape et pour écouter ce qu'ils ont à
me dire et je crois qu'il faut se mettre
à étudier les éléments qui ont marché
dans ce grand pays qu'est la alors par
exemple qu'est ce qui a marché le mieux
mais là dans des temps récents que nous
connaissons mais c'était après une
tragédie féroce et pourquoi ne le ferait
donc pas avant la tragédie parce qu'elle
sait à peu près la langue lisse après la
guerre vous dire que la guerre c'est le
conseil national de la résistance
moi je crois que tous ceux qui ont la
capacité d' étudier en france qui ont la
capacité de regarder les chercheurs le
scientifique les historiens doivent
regarder coma
là c'est construit et à comment at on pu
inventer la sécurité sociale faire voter
les alors à l'époque c'était la sécurité
sociale il faudrait inventer quoi
aujourd'hui
il faut inventer le vivre ensemble et il
faut réinventer une finalité il faut
inventer un futur on n'est que sur des
moyens est-ce qu'il faut passer à la
6ème république
est-ce qu'il faut un peu plus de voix on
écrit sur des moyens rien sur la
finalité non c'est là ce que les
français nous attendent le plus est il
faut le faire avec le peuple le peuple
qui vous pousse derrière un peuple qui à
nouveau confiance en vous et qui vous
aide dans votre livre en tout cas il ya
beaucoup de témoignages que vous
rapportez ces témoignages là ils sont
dans notre livre mais qu'est ce que vous
souhaitez qu'il devienne ces témoignages
écoutez il ne m'appartient plus je
souhaite bien entendu qu'ils soient le
plus largement possible découvert parce
que c'est des témoignages des français
et ce n'est pas un témoignage j'ai gardé
17500 comme tac au cours de ces 5 me de
kilomètres pendant près de neuf mois le
temps d'une gestation
j'ai rencontré depuis le dé préfet de
région jusque je sais pas si on peut
établir ce genre d'échec puisque l
artisan par la force armée mais même ce
pauvre homme qui n'a pas vu son arrière
grand père travailler voyez dans la
situation dans laquelle on est donc j'ai
retrouvé cet état d'esprit à tous les
niveaux à tous les étages et ça vous
donne envie d'y penser et dit croire en
tout cas et d'y croire mais pas tout
seul il faut retrouver le moyen de
reparler ensemble pour bâtir un projet
merci jean lassalle d'avoir accepté
notre invitation ce soir et d'être venu
nous parler de votre livre qui vient de
sortir à la rencontre des français